hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Game of Thrones episode 8
video so so many awesome things to talk
about now that we're in the last couple
of episodes they're really like cranking
up the WTF seriously it took them weeks
to film the last 20 minutes of this
episode let there be no more questions
as to where the budget was spent this
year and everybody always wonders
whenever ghost doesn't show up a whole
lot you don't have to use CG for stuff
like that so bigger dragons this year
more White Walkers
so here's careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet so
I'm gonna start with the really big
stuff first just a quick reminder to new
round of the giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video I'll
announce the winner in my Q&A tomorrow
the person that we saw in the episode
was the night's king obviously it looks
a little bit different than what he
looked like last year here this is what
he looked like in episode 4 last year as
you can see they just did a much better
job on the effects just because they
wanted him to be like a practical person
that could walk around and interact with
everyone else we really only saw his
face last year I do believe that this is
the original night's king the former
Lord Commander that was turned marry the
white Walker bride and then came back to
rule over the Nights Watch slate like a
his own small personal fiefdom even
though that last big scene of him
raising up all those dead people and
turning them into whites was it was a
big deal
any white Walker can do that they all
have magic the night's king just has
more powerful magic they just had him do
it for dramatic effect you know just to
show off some swagger so let's move
through top 7 WTF just chronologically
through the episode starting with Tyrion
advising Daenerys to banish Sir Jorah
technically that wasn't his advice he
was advising her to not kill Jorah so
Daenerys chose banishment as a mercy but
it was still really sad you do feel for
sir Jorah especially that he knows that
his days are numbered because of the
greyscale there really isn't like an
official timeline as to how long it
takes greyscale to take over your body
only that it happens really quickly like
within a matter of weeks probably it
really didn't even look like it was that
much worse so I'm guessing he's only had
the affliction for a day or two I'm
expecting though but by the finale like
if he if he looks at it again it'll be
way worse it'll be covering like most of
his forearm I'm not positive but I think
that this is also the first time you
know the Tyrion and Jorah Daenerys seen
in the throne room where it's said out
loud that Jorah is in love with Daenerys
like openly and love she probably
already knew but I mean it's some
different when it said with both
characters looking at each other if
you're a little confused as to why he
took himself back to use on where he
said you know you let me fight in the
big pit I win I'm yours
he knows that he's gonna die so it
doesn't matter I think he wants to have
one last chance to prove his love to
Daenerys visibly it's like his ride off
into the sunset
you know if I'm gonna die I might as
well do something big make some big
grand gesture to the person I love on to
number six though Tyrion explains to
Daenerys why she can't just march into
Westeros this is all about the
difference between gaining the support
of the people versus the support of the
nobles Tyrion explains to her that you
know she's freed all the slaves and save
her space so they love her but all the
nobles still hate her she's got that big
problem in Mereen right now remember
Daario wanted her to pull a red wedding
moment and kill all the heads of the
houses in the city Tyrion was just
reminding her that politics are much
bigger deal in Westeros she's gonna need
support from the nobles he's valuable to
her because politics or what he does
really well but it was just it was fun
seeing them chat together two terrible
children of two terrible fathers and if
you didn't recognize it whenever she was
giving that speech you know I'm not
going to stop the wheel I'm going to
break it that was from the trailer you
could take that to mean a lot of
different things
I feel like Daenerys and in her own mind
thinks that she's going to march into
Westeros and get rid of a lot of the
inequalities between the really rich
people and the really poor people
Tyrion actually suggested to her that
she stay in the east maybe this is where
you belong but as Daenerys said this is
not my home that that's basically the
show telling you that no she will not
stay put forever eventually they will
make their way to Westeros but that
that's still a long ways off I feel like
that's not gonna happen for a while
remember in order to get all those
people over to Westeros they still need
ships which they do not have right now
that seems like a season six problem to
solve I think the funniest part though
was when Tyrion said the only person I
trust more than Faris is my brother and
dinner she's like you mean the one that
killed my father and he's like yep if
that's one moving out to number five
Sansa finds out that her brothers are
not dead she seems like she's getting
stabby ER and stabby ER so I'm hoping at
some point she just snaps and does some
sort of reek type torture upon Ramsay or
Miranda or even Theon himself it would
definitely go a long ways towards
addressing some of the issues with Sansa
this season so far she's kind of backs a
little bit
I mean she started in a really powerful
place and we got onto all this Ramsey
business and now it finally looks like
she's going to do something about it
could you just get that like that
glimmer of hope in her eye where she's
like wait a minute my brothers are still
alive where did they go everybody always
asks me about Rickon like where's Rickon
so in the context of the story he is
just with OSHA hiding off on an island
both the show and George are Martin just
just don't need him the story doesn't
need him right now so he'll probably
come back at some point or he could just
live on that island for the rest of his
life and yes his direwolf shaggy dog is
still alive - bran of course you know
ZUP training with the three-eyed raven
way north of the wall he won't be back
till season six but he will be back
because he's a really important
character on to number four arya gets
ready to take her first mission taking
on a new identity in the process as
predicted it doesn't look like she's
going to be changing her face but she
does have a new costume but she has a
new look this was actually on the cover
of Entertainment Weekly like before the
start of the season you can see the like
you know when she was talking to Jackie
and she almost has it down cold she
makes a few slip-ups but she's
essentially she's got this persona I
love how the waif objected to Jack and
and he just said well you know it's all
the same to the many-faced God whether
she lives or dies that might seem kind
of bleak but it just shows you how
stone-cold the faceless men are they
believe in justice that's what arias
mission is all about but they're not
really about sentiment don't expect any
hugs from them I think my favorite thing
about the audience scene though was the
way to edit it just just the way you get
to see Aria in this persona while Aria
and third-person was narrating it to
jaqen moving on to number three pretty
much everybody is telling Cersei to
confess her crimes before the trial this
was a nice follow-up to the moment where
she almost like hallucinating Aria the
way they edited it it made it seem that
way
she was an actual hallucinating Aria but
it's a nice follow up on arias prayer
because Cersei is definitely high on
that list so we have Qyburn telling
Cersei that in no uncertain terms she
will not get a fair trial so the only
way out is to confess it's a little hard
to tell you know which crimes of Circe's
that they know about right now
Qyburn said that they know about the
incest in King Robert's death but those
are all things that Lancel told them I
don't think Lancel knows about all of
jaime and cersei these children so when
they say incest just forget about that
briefly the only way that they would
find out about that is that
circe were to confess that really this
was a battle between Cersei and that
none it was it was kind of like they
were playing the game of faces like she
was just getting whacked and whacked and
whacked for not confessing one of the
best Cersei scenes this week though was
when she got so desperate that she was
sucking water off the floor of the black
cells the show doesn't do it justice
like these are literally like the
dirtiest places you could go to inside
for maybe flea bottom on to number three
all he asks Samwell why John has to help
the wildlings in every episode since
John announced his plan whatever all
they shows up he just keeps coming back
to this they killed my family why are
you doing this there is definitely a
reason for this because all he's
actually a really small character he's
probably gonna end up doing something
really crazy that gets tied up in a big
book plot that they don't get into just
to avoid spoilers here's the thing about
where Ali's headspace is right now and
what Samwell told him you know you have
to think about making hard choices
things that seem wrong now but in the
long term or right Samuel was talking
about Jon getting the wildlings that
obviously you know very hard thing to do
right now but long term they need them
to fight the white walkers Ollie though
in like a really nasty twist of that is
probably thinking the exact opposite
thing he's gonna do something to satisfy
his need for a revenge in the short term
that will wind up in the long term being
really really bad I don't wanna make too
many predictions
you know what those long-term
consequences of what Ollie does could be
we'll have to wait till after the finale
though but that's something really
interesting that you guys should all
remember wants number two Jon Snow
arrives at hardhome with tormund
Giantsbane they're greeted of course by
the Lord of Bones which we haven't seen
in forever I think the last time we saw
him was when John first tried to
infiltrate manses camp way way back the
Lord of bones is like the wildlings
version of Ollie he's like I don't
understand why we have to do this this
bullcrap look at that pretty crow you
have there you know until torment just
beats the crap out of him with his own
weapon everything that happened in that
meeting with the elders is just to like
show us on screen the consequences of
what happens when you don't work
together just speaking in terms of
numbers John said about 5,000 people
agreed to go with them not including
tens tens definitely against working
with the crows which I thought was
really funny that he dubbed John King
crow you could twist that metaphor into
like a night's king reference because he
was a crow himself and he was commander
of the Nights Watch
just like John is but they have about
5,000 wildlings and when you look at
Shoreline like you can see just bodies
for miles too bad it seems like 90% of
those people are now whites in the army
of the night's king I know is that they
were running away it seems like they
left the dragon class but remember
Stannis said that Dragonstone is full of
dragonglass so like they can go get more
if they need to the battle itself was
like the hardest thing for them to shoot
this season enter in terms of time it
took the longest I mean the episodes
typically take anywhere between like 8
in two weeks to film this was like most
like twice that but finally my number
one WTF the night's king takes a weird
interest in Jon Snow
notice how long his gaze lingers on
Jon's snow as he shatters a regular
white Walker with his blade with long
claw the reason they showed the White
Walkers shattering regular weapons with
his ice blade is because they wanted
that big Valyrian steel reaction
whenever Jon Snow's blade did not smash
very effective in the exploding ice
effect way better than when Samwell
killed the white Walker
I know it seems like it hasn't been that
long but visual effects get a lot better
every year just the technology gets that
much more advanced so Jon Snow versus
white Walker
Jon wins big they get away but they lose
big time because all those people are
whites now it's almost like he was
giving them the middle finger while he
was raising all those whites up but it
does seem like the night's king has
taken a perverse interest in Jon in the
same way that Melisandre has taken a
perverse interest in him so it's like
he's stuck between the forces of a god
and the forces of the great other part
of me feels like this is just the show
putting the question to you you know
like which side will he fall on will the
night's king turned Jon into another
night's king or will Melisandre do
something else you know turned him into
his aura high that feels like a question
that they're not gonna answer this
season it just is just way too big
they're gonna save that for later here's
my big question for you guys do you
think that the night's king is taken an
interest in Jon what do you think he
wants to do with him for those asking
about hardhome just because I didn't do
a bonus video on it it's in in the
context of A Song of Ice and Fire it's
like this roanoke type settlement you
know where by the original inhabitants
like you know way way long time ago just
suddenly vanished it's believed that
they were captured by slavers but it has
something of like this ghostly pallor
over it that people think that hardhome
is haunted but the wildlings are so
desperate that they don't care that's
why they're holed
there it's literally like the only
civilized port on Westeros north of the
wall so it's at the only place you can
go where you can dock ships this battle
with the white walkers only gonna make
those ghost stories that people tell
about hardhome that much worse but but
you get the idea like it is like a
cursed place a couple of things we have
to look forward to Kevan Lannister is
back and hates Circe's guts he's taking
control of the small council he doesn't
care about her at all he just like yeah
whatever who cares about her so we have
that trial to look forward to I'm
expecting like it to be a nice perverse
twist ontarians trial from last season
and Jaime hasn't responded to
communications although in the teaser
for the next episode we do see that he's
going to be meeting with Turan Martell
to decide what his fate is going to be
ether has the choice to stay in Dorne or
go back to King's Landing so I'm
actually I'm really interested to see
which direction the show goes with that
it's one of the major departures from
the books in terms of storylines this
Jaime's storyline but I feel like it has
potential so I'm gonna be optimistic
about it because this episode dealt with
so many new concepts like the night's
king White Walkers the long night I'm
gonna add some links in the description
for videos that I've already done based
on some of that stuff so just check the
description so don't forget I'll be
posting the Q&A for this tomorrow and
while you guys wait for that you can
click here to learn all about your uncle
a joy there's just a rumor that he might
be cast for season six and you can click
here for last week's episode thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]